[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or à y arriver se battre à travers le
monde actuel l'adversité donner le
meilleur de soi même
je pense qu'il ya plein de gens qui
m'ont fait ses délices excellence
moi je vous parlais avec mon coeur parce
que bon mois l'excédent se définissent
au chievo vous avez chacun une forme
d'excellence
j'ai pas fait de cela est que justement
j'ai envie de le partager avec lui je
sais où je les morts de morlaàs et
génériques chignon donc si j'ai vraiment
faim à partir en live vous pouvez
toujours pas donné mais je vais
m'appuyer sur un acronyme qui et puis je
vais bien joué parce que la base de tous
les cas trouvé génial de se surpasser
le rêve d'atteindre un objectif petit
bureau ovale d'un président ne sera pas
le rêve la personne
ce petit garçon
mais les objectifs sont aussi athlétique
parfois ailleurs nous donc de l'aider à
gérer des îles voir les choses en grand
pourquoi alain possible parce que moi
c'est hermine à l'époque
moi j'ai trop pensé avant j'aidais mon
master je travaille en tant que jésus
s'est marié il a pour tout est bien là
les davis
je ne sentais pas équipés donc qu'est ce
qui s'est passé il était temps pour moi
de réaliser mon rêve un rêve qui avait
démarré il ya 20 ans ou finma dans le
désert
j'avais vu les mannequins défilent et
j'avais vu des créateurs africains
donnent une réalité à 31 ans je me suis
levé et je me suis inscrite à l'école
pour apprendre le visage ou apprendre
couture qui ont amusé à 7 la jeanne je
peux craquer remettre au pot avec des
enfants ma plusieurs navires allemands
et je me suis retrouvé j'ai mis à douter
les il prend donc des photos de placer
photo de groupe
les gens rentrés en salle et on venait
me voir
l'affichage fait vraiment de profil donc
c'était un objectif que je vivais à 15
ça a été difficile mais je voulais y
arriver parce que cette fois je savais
que si je me défends mon rêve à quoi ça
rime à vie beaucoup de gens vous battez
vous battez vous allez y aller mais
parfois vous arrivez à atteindre des
objectifs qui sur le papier
la société définit cet objectif quelque
chose comme une réussite
la réalité la réussite et c'est ce que
vous apportez le parcours que vous
faites vous savez on arrive à toucher au
pays des bisounours mais j'aime bien les
10 ou non j'aime voir un en ce monde là
où les gens se réalise par leur action
pas leur passion c'est le futur on a été
dénaturé vraiment combien de gens désolé
nous mettra que sur nous sommes cinq
tous les cinq on a fait une école de
gestion et une fois quelqu'un sommes
indignés c'est de là vous allez les
modes de gestion gestion voulez gérer
forcément pas vous gérez les âmes comme
quoi la réalité vraie sincèrement
techniquement à part le job ou si vous
entrez de stage et l'âme vous êtes entré
et les opportunités aux amis du gesppe -
est-ce que j'ai dévoré ge est ce que
vous gérez vos ambitions vlc des
questions qu'il faut vous posez pas les
questions que la société vous a imposé
de nos jours ne ment pas de réfléchir à
ce qu'on veut vraiment se combinent
apaisante à midi place et moi c'est ce
que j'ai décidé de suivre
poursuivant mon rêve est designer j'ai
vu
vous venez vivre les émotions j'espère
donner une image de l'afrique positive à
travers ce que je fais ce volume et en
donnant cette envie aux gens autour de
moi parce que pour moi l'excellence de
l'afrique passe aussi par son image
grand détour d'une de mes tenues à
l'étranger
les gens vont là où c'est super tu l'as
acheté 1,6 à pékin s'est fait en afrique
des gens en plus son regard définition
il check est commise et bien fini c'est
ma plus grande fierté c'est de pouvoir
atteindre un niveau d'excellence où les
gens ne verront pas la différence en
terme de finition et de qualité entre le
travail de chine et de travail en
occident chacun à sa vocation
mais c'est ça ce sont des petits
objectifs à atteindre
authentique hier devant le m le r2 d'une
fosse commune toujours sur vous depuis
c'est la résilience
savez vous ce que c'est l'avenir
[Rires]
dernier élément clé de l'excellence des
personnes qui sont pas revue à
l'excellence en un moment ou un autre
traversé des moments difficiles de ma
vie et je vous avais tous traversé d'une
amende d'utiliser votre vie et la
capacité à se surpasser à aller au delà
de ça détermine cette excellence elle va
pas citer à ce soit levée de l'épreuve
les gens qui réussissent pris les
enfants et fils à papa qui sont là dans
leur success story se détruisent benoît
parce qu'ils n'ont pas écrit challenge
et l'être humain
il fait pour être challenge est vous
devez vous challenge est de toute façon
si l'argent c'est bien c'est une chose
la réussite c'est une chose et si vous
vivez dans votre confort confort
matériel confort intellectuel rémois à
la fin de votre vie vous aurez eu du
matériel et de l'intérieur vous
procéderez vient cette résilience assez
l'objectif c'est le plus dur ne retrouve
dans
deux philosophies se redonner et la
plupart de mon génie qu'on a rencontrés
on a dû les maupassant
toutes les odeurs ont eu des grosses
épreuves dans le set capacitaire en ce
moment cela qu'ils sont arrivés à sion
surpasser et à sortir le meilleur de m
je vous recommande d'ailleurs il ya un
ouvrage très bon qui parle justement de
cette capacité de donner la confusion
alors ils étaient une douzaine de
l'excellence à travers la région at elle
ajouté
pour moi faire charger des ombres
souvent les gens me regardent c'est
qu'il me laisse mon histoire lorsque
tout ce qu'on vous avez je n'avais que
17 ans imaginez une enfant de 17 ans
fille de paix aurait la plus faible et
du chemin il n'y a plus de tout ce qui
comptait le plus ou moins je vais le
matin le soir du trophée ce que j'avais
les abus on est désolé je ne savais pas
si je serai encore ici les gens me
disent comment vous avez vu pour sûr
vote pour survivre à table ont surpassé
ça y est la question ne se pose même
quand je ne vienne pas eu chaud je
n'avais pas les tuer je réfléchis je me
ferais insiste je vous serai plainte
je ne serai plus toilé sur moi si
j'avais raté ma vie de toute façon on va
trouver toutes les excuses possibles à
hawaïi
aussi vous avez ce qui lui est arrivé de
normal non c'est pas normal c'est pas
normal
la vie nous donne des espaces et moi là
dans la foulée que je vous donne aux
difficultés dépassement qui dira
toujours lui machin vous devriez vous
avez chacun d'entre vous des projets
super vous allez des ruines si j'avais à
montrouge si j'avais accès à des
financements et si c'est si je vais pas
vous dire si jamais je devais vous dire
malgré le fait que les solutions à tous
je vais y arriver
le défi ça prendra du temps peut-être
décembre n'a plus d'énergie en si vous
êtes déterminé si vous êtes vivre
l'expérience de rendre hommage à ces
mots je vais chaque croyez-moi le métier
de styliste
on se prend la tête avec le tailleur
avec mes petits seulement avec le
bijoutier avait que 20 à sept a prise de
tête
on voit sur le fraudeur les gens
n'imaginent pas pour arriver à tuer nos
robes lettres des galères protège
jusqu'au moment du repas ça je
n'imaginais pas toutes les catastrophes
consulter et à chaque moment c'est le
mans une cet qui nous il faut avancer
une face on a une vision c'est ce qu'ont
de véhiculer comme une motion j'espère
de véhiculer une vision de la vision de
l'excellence pour moi c'est ça c'est la
beauté africaine n'a pas hésité à faire
de belles choses avec peu chacun d'entre
eux
vous avez les capacités de grêle avait
remanié d'éducation c'est le meilleur
outil d'éducation
allez allez travailler à les étudier
aujourd'hui c'est ça notre jeunesse
aujourd'hui il ya des passionnés pense
pas mais on pourra aller copier ce qui
se passe dehors tout a déjà été fait la
voir le mans leur système est déjà
entendu ces provisions lyonnais le
système a fait ses preuves de l'échec
chômage insécurité
il ya des manifestations des grèves il
est tentant ce créneau bon chemin
le prénom propre vision et ça c'est à
vous de le faire c'est la jeunesse
d'aujourd'hui qui doit sûr de créer
c'est pas en regardant eyetv que vous
avez des solutions
[Applaudissements]